early on I was gonna work for this
director and he said to his camera you
know he looked pretty good in his last
movie why don't you look at that one see
what they see you soon how they did that
the play came back and they said
whatever you how they kept them in the
shadows
he was tits it it kept me in the shadows
on Tootsie I think we were all in the
shadows I'm tipsy you're trying to make
Dustin Hoffman look like a good look
like a half decent looking woman which
is a challenge right there every scene I
was in was with Dustin and you know we
had an understanding after the first ser
rehearsal that it was like you know
there's a way you can make a scene
completely all about the other person
you know by the fourth time it was like
I made it all really about him anyone
okay let's do one more and then we did
it and was completely even-handed
because that's the way he knew it was
supposed to be but he really had to know
that I could he could trust me so every
scene from them I would do I would be
doing these terrible upstaging things
but which warden Aaron people were
considered obscene in jail but because
you can't upstage I'm a command in
panties in a girdle you know kind of
problem you know you could do anything I
left the movie and I came back to visit
like a couple weeks later and there they
were there fighting at all over again
and I had this sort of Walter Huston
home
that moment and show your Sarah Madre
where he's like dancing on it's right
onto here eight you don't even see it
they're standing right on top of it you
don't even see because that's like you
don't even know how good this movie is
you guys are just a couple of poses this
is so good you have no it even when
they're fighting you look at the scene
book this is amazing this is amazing
in Sydney acted before and after but he
was never like he was really he was
really good as agent he said I didn't
feel the same character you're playing a
tomato you know it was like that's what
I mean a tomato doesn't have feelings
you know it was really fantastic scene